so I got a million questions for you I'm
going to start with some curveballs
because you've been asked a lot of the
same stuff I think uh probably all day
and yesterday and the day before um if
someone has never seen anything you've
directed before what is the first thing
you'd like them watching and why oh uh
of what I've made yep
uh I guess any of my movies I'd be happy
for that any of them
um but uh yeah I I fo is very special to
me because it it it kind of brings uh
all of my film making qualities you know
I have done commercials for like 20
years and done a lot of kind of um
fictional elements um cre creative
elements and this movie kind of has all
that Humanity but there are some sci-fi
elements and a bit of genre and so I I
guess this is the full spectrum of my
film making capabilities in foe right
you can true or false uh you decided to
direct foe because you got to uh create
a futuristic
car no
false false I'm totally I'm totally
messing with toly false right I'm I'm
joking although that must have been cool
either way to get to create something
anyway um which of your films actually
changed the most in the editing room in
ways you didn't expect oh God I think
they all all of them have um I guess
with foe um it was the most interesting
one because I can never experience this
movie as a first- Time viewer you know
because I know it so I guess the thing
is that I I couldn't fully understand is
is what it's like for a first-time
viewer dealing with all of the Mysteries
and the questions that are there for you
know nearly half the movie um so I guess
from the editing point of view it was
really about calibration and having to
put it in front of someone that knows
nothing about anything and and kind of
tracking their understanding of what we
think they're understanding so um this
was probably the most unique editing
experience I've ever had in that regard
if that makes sense well the other thing
about foe specifically in the edit is
that I mean I watch the movie and as
soon as it was over I'm like oh my God
this would be a completely different
movie The when I would when I rewatch it
so can you sort of talk about that
aspect that you are um there's a lot of
stuff you're revealing and it's about
when and where you choose to reveal
information um and and the fact is the
second time you watch it it's going to
be a completely different film yeah I
mean it is two movies in one and um
that's not an easy thing to pull off and
but that was the thing that really
excited us I guess we had to really
think about we have to be truthful
because if you watch it the second time
it won't feel real if that makes sense
so we had to really make sure that
everything all the choices we're making
were were truthful but then we had to
kind of hide the truth through our
choices um so that would be through
performance and where we put the camera
and point of view um I guess all of that
was what really excited us and that
that's what I meant in terms of the
editing was like trying to calibrate how
much we reveal of the real story versus
the one we think is happening um and not
only that the actors themselves are
emotionally going through a multitude of
different truths and different ideas as
well um so yeah I mean it was a lot of
fun it's like an eer you know everywhere
you look at it there's another
perspective I guess yeah um what was it
though about this material that said I
have to do this I'm going to spend the
next two three years of my life making
it you what pulls you in I mean it was
the heart of the story and that's hen
and um how she wants to live her life
and um be herself and find her agency
and and I think hen for me
represents uh somebody that appreciates
that life is short and it's precious and
she wants to um not deny that part of
herself and I guess that's something
that that's how I see the world and um I
love what she fights for and I believe
in that and I feel like
we're all a little bit sleep at the
wheel in society and um you know hens
telling us to wake up and to kind of uh
take note that's why I loved it well one
of the things also is that um it really
it's it's it takes place primarily in
one
location and um it's so different than
what you've done before was it nice to
have such a contained piece and what was
that like as a director working in such
a contained environment oh man you
nailed it I love it it's it was like um
a dream come true to make my actors
become the Landscapes my action movie I
mean just going deep into performance um
and nuance and mystery and all of those
things that was super exciting to me but
the material was great because there was
a lot of complexity that we could
explore in subtle ways so I I guess it
was the right material to do it um and
um I loved it I loved that challenge it
it it actually inspired me immensely you
obviously this whole movie rides on the
three performances so when did you know
uh that you had that this was going to
be something that these these guys were
going to be great because it you know
they're all great actors but you really
don't know the chemistry until you're
all together exactly I think it was
um I was I was completely fine with the
very human I was very confident with all
of the human moments but I guess the
moments that were more complex where
there's lots of secret Rivers playing
through the scene I think that was the
stuff that uh I was most anxious about
so I think it wasn't until we were in
rehearsal and we were rehearsing one of
those key
scenes where we kind of found the
musicality of the scene and how much
people were revealing how much people
weren't and just feeling that out
together and then when we found that I
felt really excited about where this was
going to go but it wasn't until then
that felt like it was all going to work
does that make sense 100% did you ever
do any scenes because you are revealing
information as you go
in certain scenes um did you ever end up
having like someone do a little bit more
in one scene of like more of a reveal or
more of a playing it a certain way in
case you needed that in the edit as long
as it was truthful so for instance if if
if one character was revealing a truth
while the other one's looking at them
clearly the other actor would have to
say in a real moment what are you doing
you know um so I guess um to a point yes
um but I think it was more about
coverage and point of view so you know
when someone's backs to someone then
you've got all this
availability to to to kind of explore a
secret I guess um so yes I was I we had
to make sure that we had the first
viewing and the second viewing I guess
covered in the most exciting way going
into the edit what do you think soon to
be fans of this film would be surprised
to learn about the making of the film
that was shot in Australia
maybe that's a pretty surprising thing
uh
um I don't know I've got no idea I have
to leave that up to them sure how long
did you actually have to shoot the movie
um how many days did you have you know
to actual make it do you remember that's
I don't fully remember it was pretty
standard it was pretty standard shoot
whatever that is sure so you didn't feel
like you oh my God we have to make five
pages today no um there was definitely
some
ambitious moments um but it was it was a
good schedule um and you know there was
definitely 3 or four days that weren't
fitting in the schedule that we had to
somehow absorb so you know you choose
your battles you you choose the scenes
where you want the time and there's some
scenes where you're you know you're
shooting them in 20 minutes you know
that you just are and um you kind of
have
to make sure the preparation's in place
to to achieve those moments like any
filmmaker but no it wasn't it didn't
feel like I was under um crazy duress
even though there's always that pressure
how do you typically like to direct on
set and what do you do when you're not
getting exactly what you want are you
one that gives like a slight little like
just a little like this or how do you
like to craft your performance onet I
mean I do whatever I can to get it and
um and and every situation will change I
guess um I mean it's fairly cliche but I
I don't want to give them the result of
what I'm looking for I'm more interested
in witnessing choices so I guess it's
really together I would take the actor
separately out of the space if if I have
that opportunity um to talk privately um
maybe adjust one so that so it affects
the other I mean you know all those
usual directorial Things Music uh
sometimes I use Music depends on the
actor the style of actor like some
actors don't want any of that um
inspiration they just want to have a
conversation where some people really
Thrive off being shown an image for
example to inspire a scene or a small
conversation or a note
um uh so so yeah there's there's not one
thing it's a myriad of things but I'm I
guess my driving principle is
to uh again just try and witness a
choice I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm you know I'm
not going to expect that makes sense
from friends and family screenings or
test screenings wherever you showed it
to what were the things that you learned
that you didn't expect that you needed
to now go in and adjust the movie
because they told you stuff you're like
oh how did I not see this yeah look
the challenge here is that there's some
audience members that get things a lot
quicker than others and um and and which
one do you
serve because for the intelligent you
know the ones that can kind of get
something straight away um because
that's the way their brains are wired um
you don't want to be too obvious because
they get frustrated and then if you're
not obvious enough then there's half the
audience that don't get it so I guess we
we just had to decide um what was what
was the deal breaker you know and we and
and I guess that reveal scene it it had
to be cleared every single person in
that audience what's going on it just
had to be otherwise the last third of
the movie would be impossible to watch
so I guess um that was the scene that we
were most critically testing with the
Myriad of audiences to make sure that
99.9% would get it if that makes sense
so um you know and it was totally
different to what I thought it had to be
to achieve that the beginning of the
film has text on screen sort of setting
you up to the world how much did you
debate what text
to say in that on that screen and did it
change along the way there was never
going to be text on the screen um but
when we were doing some tests you know
we we
underestimated how much the audience was
working you know they were kind of in
this world they didn't know and and when
when he was talking about space they
thought what are we in the future so
there's all of these there were all of
these questions that the audience was
having to kind of understand and consume
and it was and it was kind of
almost taking all their energy away from
the story itself and and and the one
that we wanted them to be watching so by
simply adding the title at the front
just gave this enticing uh sense of
context that um actually just took away
some of those Mysteries and allowed
people to be really engaged um in what
is still very ambiguous and mysterious
it was really fascinating rather than
going in and edit re-editing all the
scenes just by adding a tiny bit of
context at the beginning created this
completely exulting relationship with
the film yeah I really wonder what it
would have been like for me seeing it
without that text because I saw it with
with text so I that's actually I'm
wondering about that you know uh anyway
well yeah I mean there's there's two
there's two things that happen yeah two
very different things I'm I'm so curious
with this film was there something else
you thought about directing since your
last movie or was this the thing that
you'd sort of gravitated toward words
I'm just curious about you know um if
there was something else you came close
on well I was actually um flirting with
Tron 3 um you know I was kind of getting
in the Weeds on that um but I guess foe
was something that as an artist and as a
human being I was very very excited
about um so it it it was something that
I felt passionate about um and once I
find something I want to do I just kind
of stay on it until it's done I am a
huge fan of Tron and I'm to imagine your
version of Tron 3 right now how does it
look well I think I think the main thing
is that getting to design in that world
must be very enticing because it's
visually like nothing else you know and
you although I guess Tron 3 takes more
place in the real world but whatever you
know you still get to design cool
absolutely yeah know look there's a big
part of me that loves that stuff and um
you know I've just got to
find it just has to be character
character driv driven for me to to to
want to fully engage with it um but I
I'm I'm a big fan of um I'm a big fan of
of those movies so yeah I've just got
you know when I find the right one I'll
be giving it a go what are you thinking
about for the future is there scripts
that you're working on right now or
things you were thinking about there's
nothing I can talk about but there's
definitely um a limited series that I'm
I'm developing um and an original idea
that I'm putting some ideas around a
slightly bigger canvas original idea um
but you know it's
it's it's a slow process finding
something that you know as you say
you're going to spend years of your life
on so and and it needs to kind of affect
me and and give me that fire in the
belly otherwise I'm not doing it well
one of the things about series I mean
I'm not sure if it's the same with you
but I'm watching more and more
television now because you get to spend
so much more time with characters and um
and you know the budgets on series can
be pretty expensive nowadays yeah I
guess um you know Top of the Lake I
really enjoyed doing because it was very
filmic um I guess what I have an allergy
to is the kind of formula nature of
Television it's almost the formula is is
kind of um birthing the creative choices
um and and I think that's I find that a
little frustrating um I like it when TV
feels more like a novel and it's very
purist and exciting and and I feel like
there's so much I mean it is being done
but there's so much room for limit
television to be pushing the form so
much more than it is and um so I do
think it's an exciting space and it is a
different story to tell it is it's a
novel you know and um you can go with
that character for an episode that one
and and and you can drive forward uh in
a really exciting way that you can't in
a movie um so yeah if it's if it's um
Brave and um and and and exciting that
I'm in on that note I need to stop with
you I'm just going to say I am a big fan
of your work and I really do appreciate
getting some time with you today if
there's ever anything I can do on
collider to help uh please let me know
you're gentlemen thank you so much
appreciate it uh have a fantastic day
thank you so
much